it's the question everyone asks after a
mass shooting how did this happen again
unfortunately we already know the answer
we don't have sufficient gun control
laws and we can thank the NRA for that
the National Rifle Association's mission
is to defeat any legislation that might
restrict gun ownership that includes the
assault weapons ban that has been
proposed repeatedly since 2004
prohibited under that ban would have
been the rifles used in the San
Bernardino Newtown and Aurora shooting
after many of these attacks the NRA
defended assault rifles and specifically
they are 15 as necessary for civilian
self-defense and for hunting the only
thing that stops a bad guy with a gun is
a good guy with a gun
more recently the NRA fought against the
law they would have stopped anybody on
the FBI's no-fly list from purchasing
firearms and now we know that the
Orlando shooter was once on an FBI watch
list and legally purchased the weapons
he used in the attack and he's not the
first more than two thousand people on
that list purchased weapons since 2004
so why did in any of this legislation
pass well the NRA gave a lot of money to
politicians who voted against it
take senator Mitch McConnell for example
the NRA has spent over a million dollars
supporting the senator which is probably
why he voted against the no fly no gun
legislation recently McConnell said that
the NRA needed to give its approval
before Supreme Court nominee Merrick
garland could be appointed I can't
imagine that a Republican majority in
the United States Senate would want to
confirm in a lame-duck session a nominee
opposed by the National Rifle
Association but it goes far beyond him
the NRA is very effective in getting the
right people into office 90% of NRA
endorsed candidates win their elections
in the 2014 elections alone the NRA
shelled out twenty eight million dollars
including the communities devastated by
mass shootings in Arizona they
bankrolled representative martha
mcsally's Biddeford Gabby Giffords old
seat Giffords you may remember took a
bullet to the head during a mass
shooting in 2011 the NRA worked to
ensure her successor opposed gun control
but the scary thing is the NRA doesn't
just focus on political spending
Gripen government so tight that they've
made sure the CDC can't research
anything related to gun control meaning
our data on gun violence is practically
non-existent it also spends hundreds of
millions of dollars to a tax-exempt
foundation and has trained 28 million
children with its gun safety program it
really is an all-encompassing campaign
so will we ever be able to pass gun
control legislation as long as the NRA
is against it
you